[Música]
a músicos en las calles tiendas abiertas
centros comerciales atestados de
personas pero también estatuas tapadas
funerales y miles de desplazados living
convive con la normalidad y la realidad
de un país que está en guerra
mina solía ser un extra grammer muy
conocida en su país pero con la guerra
decidió abrir un refugio para
desplazados dice que ha acogido a unas
55.000 personas en su mayoría del este y
sur de ucrania
la guerra ha cambiado el 95% de mi vida
no veo ya mucho a mi familia estoy
siempre ocupa aquí 724 en el refugio
trabajando con los desplazados haciendo
papeleo
sin embargo ni na explica que vive la
situación con naturalidad sin pensar en
el momento histórico que está viviendo
para ser honesta estamos tan ocupados
con los quehaceres cotidianos que es
bastante difícil analizar lo que ha
ocurrido en este último mes
en esta ciudad de 700 mil habitantes
ahora también viven miles de desplazados
que han cambiado el rostro de él y vive
aunque la población se resiste a que la
guerra lo ocupe todo
niña no es la única que se ha
acostumbrado a su nueva vida
taras es un joven informático que forma
parte de los civiles armados que luchan
para defender a su país asegura que su
ciudad ha sobrevivido a épocas muy
negras
viva ha estado bajo muchas ocupaciones
también con la alemania nazi y como se
puede ver estos edificios siguen en pie
es decir
o desvele de shahr-e-naw
tara no tiene equilibrio y tierna su
alma
no sé qué tienen putin o sus generales
en la cabeza pero intentamos prepararnos
para los distintos escenarios
sanders guerra y paz dos polos opuestos
en cuya frontera reside ahora mismo el
ibi nadie sabe con certeza absoluta por
cuánto tiempo
[Música]